i'm dave rubin and we are
live on the youtube with another friday
panel extravaganza for you today we're
going to be talking about what's going
on up north with our neighbor in canada
it seems like there's a lot of strange
things happening
up there and we're going to unpack all
of it and joining me to discuss
are the host of the michaela peterson
podcast michaela peterson
good title for a podcast the founder of
rebel news ezra levant
and lawyer turned youtube commentator
which is the best thing you can possibly
be viva fry welcome to the reuben report
everybody
good afternoon great to be here thanks
for having me on
all right i've got three canadians uh
two in toronto michaela and ezra and
viva
you are in montreal there there's a lot
of weird stuff happening in canada we're
going to spend the half hour talking
about it
but just briefly when we all connected
each one of you have your own story
about a little bit of tech censorship
demonetization that sort of thing
ezra you're in the middle of a massive
battle right now so let's just spend
like
two minutes discussing how we've all
battled through that ezra can you just
update what's going on
with the rebel and paypal because it
doesn't sound great
sure on friday at 6 pm so after work
hours we get a terse email
from paypal just cutting us off they
don't say what we did wrong
what rule we violated what action we did
we've done over 150 000
transactions with them over 8 million
bucks perfect
customer relations we've never had a
complaint and
for five days we've tried to get them on
the phone or by email our lawyer's been
so friendly what went wrong can we fix
it
stonewalling us so yesterday we decided
all right that's enough
we're gonna sue for breach of contract
and uh
interference with economic relations we
are going to sue
paypal in canada because the way they're
conducting their business is just too
high-handed so wish us luck
yeah well you've got you've got luck
from me and i think from these guys that
you're gonna need a little more than
luck so it's good you've got a lawyer
and actually i'm talking to a lawyer
right here viva
does this guy have a chance can you
fight paypal and win
well from what i understand paypal has
arbitration clauses so
they may have to go through arbitration
but no this is
it's it's egregious it's over the top
people say you know private enterprises
can do what they want
they still have to behave uh fairly and
they have to on the one hand respect
their contracts
and they have to have fair deals with
their customers especially when you have
a business relationship and not just uh
a platform like youtube where
you know they tolerate you but ezra's
ezra's problems are next level
um compared to most of us you know i've
had the occasional video
demonetized and it's it's random it's
arbitrary some might say it's
politicized
but you know but for that it's a little
lost revenue that i know youtube is
still making revenue off of
uh but you know that's been the extent
of my problems
although all content creators are just
sort of walking a line on youtube you
want to get your message out you want to
speak
but you don't want to be shut down and
have your voice shut off sure and the
demonetization thing of course is a soft
type of censorship because it's not
direct censorship they're not stopping
your videos although when your videos
get demonetized we know that hurts them
in the algorithm so less people see them
but i would say it's soft in that we all
have to make a living and
you know that if you talk about certain
things and can't make money on it well
then you may
talk about those things less mckayla
you've had some problems with that too
right
yeah last year last july i got coved
and i released a video about my
experience with covid
which was like 18 days of a flu
and about a week after that my entire
channel was demonetized
and i didn't get any messages it was
just demonetized i contacted youtube
i was dealing with other things at the
time so it wasn't high priority but i
was
just remonetized last week
without warning for no reason i have no
idea what was going on there but i'm
i'm happy to have monetization back uh
but that was a
like almost a year the entire channel so
basically
eight months of not being able to make
money on the podcast
that is your main vocation yeah so i
think i think everyone gets that but
let's let's shift to the main focus here
which is canada so
you guys all know this i've spent a
bunch of time up in canada i i
toured with michaela's dad up in canada
i love visiting canada i think the
people are wonderful
there's an expression of freedom up
there that's great and it's just a great
country and
you've got room and there aren't a lot
of people which is nice it's all just
wonderful up there
except something ain't right guys
something has happened in this
last year ezra i'll throw to you first
what is going on
we're going to show some video in a
moment but what what would you say the
general temperature
is in the in the north at the moment
well our political class has become
uniform
what do i mean by that there are ten
provinces each has a government and
opposition
but all the governments and all the
opposition parties
even if it's a liberal government or a
conservative government
they're all in favor of the lockdown so
you have no political
dissidence at all whereas in the united
states you've got iran desantis on one
side and a gavin newsome on the other
side you have 50 different
approaches in canada it's uniform
secondly
the media is completely into the
lockdowns they're
cheerleaders for it finally travel in
and out of canada even to the u.s which
used to be so commonplace
is extremely restricted and i think
they're making it difficult on purpose
14 day lockdowns when you come home you
have to
go to a covid jail basically stay at a
coveted hotel quarantine center for
three days
they're trying not to let people travel
so add in complete political uniformity
media uniformity and no one can see what
america or the uk are like
this country is like a hermetically
sealed lockdown
north korea and i know that sounds
insane but there was just a study the
other day
that showed that canada is in a strange
league of countries like north korea and
china
for extreme lockdowns there's no
political diversity here
and we don't have a ron desantis up here
we don't have
uh skeptical media it's the
agreeableness of canadians which is
normally so nice
this is a terrible time for everyone to
be so agreeable with such a bad thing
right and i think perhaps your problem
with paypal might have a little
something to do with the fact that you
actually have been reporting on this
stuff
over at rebel viva you're in montreal
and i've seen some just
absolutely crazy videos about lockdowns
and you know times that you have to be
indoors and just all sorts of banana
stuff
it's a you know we say it's a slippery
slope it's a slippery slope until you
hit the edge and then it's a free fall
and you have in quebec our premier le go
in january declared a four-week curfew
and i'm putting four-week curfew
because we're now into month four of it
and it was it was imposed at the time
to stem a rise in cases not to overwhelm
the hospital
icu's over the holidays we're four
months later
from what i can tell now the number of
people in the icu and hospitalizations
are lower than what they were at the
time and the discussion is not even
how are we still in this curfew it's
there's no discussion as to how long
this curve is going to last
it just goes from react you know
preventative or reactionary to
preventative to permanent
responses from the government and people
you know some people protest
some people are objecting to this but a
great many aren't
the when what ezra says you know the
media is in the bag of the government
i listen to daytime radio they're beyond
cheerleaders
they are getting one to you know agree
to accept
this is going to be the new norm it's
not so bad it's for our own good
and when you realize that you know the
federal government
funds the cbc to the tune of a billion
dollars or something a year
they're not going to bite the hand that
feeds them in quebec
our government is you know paying for
covet awareness which is radio
placements television placement
advertising radio and television which
are star for ad dollars they're not
going to complain about this
so it's this incestuous relationship
where the government
funds the media the media props up the
message of the government and
you know proverbially shuns anybody who
dares to disagree
yeah michaela are you shocked how
quickly
even though as viva said you know
canadians or sorry as ezra said you know
canadians are nice
canadians are friendly they're open
they're decent they're tolerant
but are you still despite that shocked
how quickly it seems like so many people
have just folded
well if you look on social media and on
the response to this
i have seen the negativity towards it
growing so before when it was like
hey you know the reason we're still in a
lockdown is because you're going to
visit people like stay at home so people
were angry at each other for
for not staying at home and i've slowly
vaguely seen that change into you know
this has gone on long enough how long is
this going to continue
we've been in a stay-at-home mandate for
months
like the downtown area i live in a condo
downtown and it's a mess there are tents
everywhere there are
some parks that have outhouses in it
because there are so many people
intense if you walk down queen street a
whole bunch of the
stores are boarded up it's really sad
and really depressing
and people are scared but i think
people are slowly starting to get angry
but i mean it's taken
way too long like we're way past what's
reasonable at this point so
yeah i'm like i'm saddened and surprised
yeah and i i mean as recently as a
couple weeks ago i wanted to go to
toronto so that i could interview your
dad and they weren't even allowing
international travel and do you guys
know is that is that still the case i'm
guessing it is right
the court the court just upheld the uh
the quarantined mandate at these
government designated quarantine
facilities
the court says you know said it's a it
is a reasonable measure to protect
against the risks of international
spread of the virus um you know we've
that was the other thing by the way
media supports the government that
subsidizes them and the courts thus far
have you know not been courageous enough
to say at some point we either live in a
free society and we either have a
constitution or we don't
but when these infinitesimal risks
can warrant or justify forcible
confinement
in they call it a hotel but it's located
in a hotel
the courts are sanctioning this and so
yeah they're still in effect and the
courts basically gave it the blessing
it's just extraordinary so i do want to
point out though that you guys aren't
the only three people fighting back
because
even though canadians are nice and
smiley and welcoming
we're seeing tons of it on the street in
terms of pushback so we're gonna throw
to a compilation video right now
[Music]
i was on public property
why don't i have the right to speak
what's on my heart in the protest
you have to wear a mask if you don't
you're going to be detained
[Music]
she's just carrying a sign that's all
that's unacceptable in canada
what was her name ma'am
[Music]
[Music]
i mean it's just evil stuff you guys
have seen this i'm sure most of the
people watching i hope most of the
people watching have seen some of this
ezra you guys
if it wasn't for rebel i probably
wouldn't have seen half of the amount of
stuff
that i've seen and i have no problem
saying like this is
nazi style tactics when you have people
that are just following orders
arresting people for expressing
themselves can you give me a sense of of
the types of people that are out there i
know the media will probably these are
far right wingers out there right they
must be racist people or something
and they're far right wingers but i
suspect that's not really the case
you know what's so interesting i see a
realignment
when robert f kennedy jr when naomi wolf
who have
typically been regarded as progressive
are worried about this you have people
who are more into natural health
you have people who love working out you
have small
business people people who opened their
dream was to open a restaurant
lots of working class folks for whom the
lockdown isn't great
there's a lockdown class they love it
because they've got a nice big backyard
maybe they got a country home
it's a big staycation for them watch
some netflix order in fast food
but what if you're in a small apartment
with no backyard and yet you're not
allowed to go out because there's a
curfew in montreal
a city built for going out and about and
so i think that calling them right wing
there are some conservatives
who are skeptical of the state
definitely i would call myself that
but i have never worked with more people
on the left
who are against police uh
you know out of control police
and let me just go i was just thinking
of a list of people who would normally
oppose
police brutality you would have the
opposition
silence you have the media silent you
would have courts
silent you have law professors you would
have our version of the aclu
the canadian civil liberties association
silent
and now you have the canadian government
introducing a youtube censorship build
called bill c10 and i'm thinking why why
now
because that last vestige of individual
dissidents
is on social media including our own
youtube channels um
the the police in montreal track our guy
yankee pollock they call him jew media
they
they they've issued him dozens of
tickets they for thousands of dollars
they've slammed our people against cars
handcuffed them taken them to police
stations
where is the left and i
so i think that things are actually
there some canadians who
love this authoritarianism they find it
they find it thrilling
and ezra over this over the winter i was
at the park where they had just put in a
new
um toboggan run and there's some
journalists there and you're speaking of
the people who love this
i overheard the journalists having a
discussion you know talking about the
lockdowns and then saying what are you
doing this weekend oh i'm going to my
house in the eastern townships
and there are people who support it
because they're benefiting from it
because it doesn't harm them as much as
other people
but i in my own day-to-day discussions
with people who
i don't say that i'm on the right but i
know these people are on the left they
start to turn around
quietly the problem is nobody wants to
bear the brunt of the
public you know opposition of this so
you know they they support quietly and
and they encourage quietly but they
don't want to have their faces on this
and it goes beyond not being in
opposition aaron o'toole
the conservative opposition uh of canada
you know won't trigger an election so
that we can at least you know
duke this out in the election uh side of
it
and he's as much supporting of these
measures as anybody else so yet you
don't have any politician
except for maxine bernier from the
people's party of canada
fighting these measures or at least
openly protesting these measures
and i i don't use the nazi analogies i
don't like them they always
they're easily misunderstood but jason
kenny
the premier from alberta i think like
two or three years ago tweets out
something very you know critical of
china about how the car
you know a human shield being built
around a church and this is how you
fight communism
and three years later he's literally
putting up barricades around a church
and imprisoned locking up for over a
month a pastor a christian pastor
all because he's holding services and so
you fight
you fight the demon long enough you
eventually become the demon and it seems
our politicians have become the demons
yeah so i want to get to the pastor in a
second because it's just an insane story
but you mentioned maxine bernier and you
know i
i did a couple events with him in canada
and one of them went really viral when
there was this elderly woman
in a in a walker trying to cross the
street and they're yelling at her that
she's a nazi
and of course it turns out that her
husband actually fought the nazis
in world war ii but but his ideas and
the ideas of the people party of canada
are looking pretty good right now
because two three years ago they were
screaming about freedom
but uh michaela ezra mentioned bill c-10
i think you could probably link some of
this stuff back to bill c-16 that your
dad was talking about four or five years
ago
because he didn't want the government to
compel speech
and in essence right now you have the
government cracking down on people's
speech
yeah and this one is i would say this is
far worse than the bill
my dad was fighting against because that
was just a little
a little area of freedom of speech that
he was focused on
and this is youtube youtube censorship
for the country of canada it's
absolutely absurd
i hope it's not going to go through i
don't see that going through
but i'm also way more positive i think
than
perhaps the other two guys in this
conversation
what's the reason for the positivity
like what what's the thing that you see
in the distance that gives you hope
i can't imagine that people in canada
want their youtube censored
like you'd think that people could
self-censor if they don't want to watch
a video
then at least they should have the
option to say no i just don't see that
holding up in court what do you guys
think do you think that's actually going
to go through
well actually and dave for the benefit
of your audience who might not know what
bill c-10 is
basically playing a little further yeah
it's an act to amend the broadcasting
act
which would uh which would impose the
obligations on digital streaming
uh the same obligations that are imposed
on traditional media radio and
television which is
a certain amount of it has to be
canadian created canadian theme
uh you know failing which there will be
certain penalties or sanctions
so originally bill c10 was intended to
exclude user-generated content
on social media youtube twitter facebook
etc the liberal government
discreetly quietly in the midst of a
pandemic
removed the original exclusion that they
had included
so now bill c-10 would in fact govern
user-generated content on platforms like
youtube
so if you know i'm a canadian i could
not create any more canadian content
except i talk a lot about american stuff
so in theory
i could be required to talk about a
certain amount of canadian materials
or my channel could be suppressed or
deprioritized because it's not in
compliance
with this bill c10 and the regulations
the requirements that are currently
imposed
on traditional legacy media like radio
and television right so in essence i
think we're probably all in agreement
that michaela's right the people
don't really want this but i think what
you're all sort of saying here is you
have a political class that actually
doesn't really care
ezra well look uh the cbc this was
alluded to earlier
is the largest news organization in
canada it gets a government budget of
about a billion and a half dollars a
year so extrapolate that in america
that would be like a 15 billion a year
grant
to let's say pbs it's larger than
all private news media combined so it's
the dominant player
still that wasn't enough for justin
trudeau so he put all the newspapers on
a bailout
so about 99 of the media in canada are
either owned by the government
or subsidized by the government that
last one percent
are the grassroots independence and i
put us in that category and a few other
small guys
but that so irks the pm because as long
as there's one voice
it it can start he can snowball and
thus c10 which would seek to regulate
youtube it would be like if the fcc
in the united states regulated the same
way they would regulate howard stern
when he was on terrestrial radio
if they could regulate your youtube
channel but it goes further give me 30
seconds on this day
we have a heritage minister i call him
the censorship minister
because in his official mandate letter
like his job description from the prime
minister
the first point is give money to
broadcasters i'm not kidding you can
look it up
the second point is bring in
uh enormous financial punishments for
social media companies
that don't take down harmful posts
within 24 hours
that is literally the second priority
for the heritage minister in canada
so what happens if you have a 24-hour
period
any accusation you can't have a due
process the government
compelling facebook youtube twitter
google instagram
to take harmful not illegal harmful
things down within 24 hours
and the minister said that includes
taunting politicians
and he said he said this that
one possible remedy he calls the nuclear
option he said this at a canada 2020
conference
includes the ability to block people
from even uploading things
this sounds like north korea that is
what justin trudeau proposes to canada
it's a reminder
that he always loved castro that he said
china was the country he most admires
dave justin trudeau has been telling us
who he is for years
he really is that guy he really does
want to regulate
even private communications youtube
twitter facebook it's real
but ezra he wears cool socks isn't that
enough
to be prime minister michaela what do
you think people actually
think about this guy like do you meet
people your age that are like oh yeah
trudeau's doing a good job or is it
simply
because his suit fits nicely and he
wears colorful socks
i don't think people are very happy with
him uh at the moment
especially with the stay-at-home mandate
most people know like no one likes the
stay-at-home mandate at this point
in ontario so people aren't happy with
him
i do i do think that he's operating
out of a place of fear though i i
i told you i'm i'm more positive in my
way of thinking i don't necessarily
think there's something
truly evil going on i would err on
just plain stupidity and fear
because i i think that's the clearest
option forward i i think i've heard
our premier talk about you know if i do
anything
else it's political suicide you know
it's causing
actual suicides but for him it's
political suicide
so i think a lot of people are operating
on fear and i think because canadians
are such a polite
people that like these guys said people
are scared to
be the bad guy and they're just waiting
waiting for it to end
but it's headed in a hopefully it
recovers when the vaccine rollout
eventually happens
if that happens it's not like they had a
year to prepare for anything
else but they had a year to prepare but
they blame
a disruption on the rollout on a
four-hour protest in montreal last
weekend
wow i don't worry about the intentions
of the the
political leaders i don't know if it's
incompetence or malice the outcome is
the same so the
the intent doesn't matter yeah it is i
did a livestream
with uh our journalist george samuelle
the other day we were talking about
putin and we were talking about the
trial of navalny in russia
and my audience was saying oh that that
trial was a sham trial
and george samuel was saying yeah the
trial was okay and here i'm sitting like
thinking
our politicians what separates them from
other dictators in the world
is only the level of politeness with
which they come down with these edicts
but but for that the outcome is probably
worse here and the measures here are
worse on the general population than
they are in other parts of the world
that we have traditionally regarded
as totalitarian or fascist regimes yeah
and
you know it comes down with a smile a
nice haircut and a nice set of socks
that can distract us
from the tyranny well it seems like the
politeness part of canadians
actually can only be pushed so far
because an estimated hundred thousand
people
showed up in montreal to protest the
lockdowns i mean that's an incredible
amount
of people for for a country that you
know usually is not protesting
its government but i want to touch on
the pastor situation because this is
just incredible let me let me just read
this to you
a pastor from alberta canada awaits a
may trial in prison after refusing a
bail agreement that would have forbidden
him from preaching
james coats who pastors grace life
church in the edmonton area
was first arrested in february after the
royal canadian mounted police
repeatedly flagged his church for
refusing to abide by public health
orders
that capped attendance at 15
capacity guys i'm not a scientician
but uh 15 percent means that covet can't
spread right that's the magic number
and that's why he should have abided by
it ezra
dave fact number one there was never a
single case of covid in his church let
alone an outbreak
fact number two he served 35 days in a
maximum security prison
because of that by the way 400 inmates
from the same prison were let go
for covet reasons because they were in
danger they put
the actual criminals out of the prison
the pastor in 35 days
and by the way being convicted of this
health order
not closing your church does not even
carry with it a jail term
so he was jailed out on bail waiting for
a trial
the the worst consequences of which
would not involve him going to jail
riddle me that one when he got out of
jail the police were so
worried that the church would recon
reconvene
that they did a dawn raid on the church
erected a large fence around it and have
since then expropriated the church and
had a continuous
24-hour a day garrison of heavily armed
police
because they don't want the church
retaken it looks like an outpost
in afghanistan the police
permanently occupy this church
now i should tell you one last thing
that's the craziest of all
not the 35 days in a maximum security
prison not police
expropriating and turning a church into
a base
but this church meets every sunday dave
in secret in an underground church
in a secret location that's china stuff
dave that's that's pakistan that's india
a secret church in hiding from the
police
in canada in 2021 and by the way
i expect as soon as tomorrow another
pastor in calgary named arthur pavlovsky
maybe you've seen the video of him
saying get out get out
he has an order that takes effect
well today actually and if he doesn't
shut down today
he risks being jailed as soon as well
today
can you mention his name again because
these videos are absolutely incredible
what is it
sure it's a polish name arthur a r t
u r pavlovsky p a w l o w s k
and and we've actually i should tell you
we're crowdfunding his legal defense
he's got a bunch of lockdown tickets
and we crowdfund civil liberties lawyers
for him
so i have an interest we're trying to
help arthur pavlovsky
but he is very stubborn the pastor in
edmonton who went to prison for 35 days
he did so
he turned himself in they would have let
him go anytime he just would not in his
conscience stop calling people to church
but he was very
peaceful like a dove this arthur
pavlovsky in calgary is more like a lion
you heard him roar
he will not go quietly i i think it's
insane
but you are about to see a second pastor
in
free canada in 2021 imprisoned
using public health as the excuse that's
what canada is looking like today so the
videos of him are absolutely incredible
and actually we'll link to the gofundme
down below and i'll donate to it and
i'll i'll promote it on twitter as well
i mean it's just incredible but that
viva to something you said before that
is why i don't mind
actually calling these guys nazis not
that they want
to necessarily round people up and put
them in camps
yet i suppose but i understand why you
don't want to just
everyone labels everything nazis and all
that stuff but the
actions the way that these people i'm
just following orders i mean we know
that was the excuse that the nazis used
in the nuremberg trials right
and it's like when you watch these
people and they're doing bad
things in the name of just following
orders
well i i just i don't use the analogy
just because you know it
it it evokes certain reactions which are
exactly why people use them archer
pavlovsky uses them
and he coming from you know where he
came from
you can't you can't argue with him when
he's going to use this because he has
seen the
the i guess the russian from free into
tyranny
um but uh ezra you forgot one thing in
the church i think they put latrines
you reported they put latrines portal
parties on the front steps of the church
and you know it's it's it's not it's
like disrespect
disregarding and crushing of the spirit
and like ezra said you know
they locked up the pastor for 35 days
the underlying charges
never themselves carried any jail time
so they get them on the breach of bail
conditions which is the only infraction
that results in the prosecution that
could result in jail time
it's it's the classic if they don't get
you on the substance they're going to
get you on the procedure
and you would have been safer at his
church
statistically than elsewhere
you still have people saying just follow
the rules it's religious people thinking
that they have special exceptions
i'm not religious but if you forget the
fundamental
sanctity of religion then you are one
step closer towards
justifying pretty much anything yeah if
i get a job
yeah go ahead the trial you mentioned of
that pastor had happened this week and
our reporter sheila gun read covered it
there was a moment in the trial she told
me that was incredible
the public health inspector kept going
to this church in edmonton they were
extremely peaceful
i've been there they're just all love
and hugs and everything
and she went there several times and she
testified under oath
she was not afraid at all but then one
day she came back with a bunch of
heavily armed police
and and the lawyer for the the pastor
said why did you do that
were you afraid of the church she said
no
she said she did it for the media she
testified
under oath that she brought armed police
to the church
as a sort of shock and awe to please the
media
the hyenas of the media who wanted to
see this church knuckle under
and to intimidate those within the
church she did not need to bring
armed police to the church she chose to
and and one of the problems here dave is
a year ago
i think most police would have been
uncomfortable being ticket writers for
public health matters
in fact you saw the new york police
department and other departments saying
we're not going to be your mass police
we're going after the real crime
but in canada and in some parts of the
uk and australia
police that had qualms about it well now
a year later that cement has hardened
and they love this new policing taking
batons to the head of guys who don't
wear a mask
oh you're not social distancing i'm
gonna hit you with a
with a police baton the the the cops who
said no what this isn't policing
they've either quit been reassigned or
or just have taken a back seat
the cops who are out there police i mean
enforcing
health orders that is not a crime that's
a serious problem that is a move
literally
to a police state policemen have no
legal authority
to implement public health laws they
never have you didn't have
actual cops with guns giving restaurants
you know or we see a mouse under your
fridge we you were shutting your
restaurant down for it wasn't an armed
cop
we have militarized this pandemic and
where are the civil libertarians dave
no listen i mean this is consistent with
sort of what i would say is the general
collapse
of the liberal left in america but i'm
glad you mentioned this idea
of you know what the cops would have
done or wouldn't have done a year ago
versus now because it's like i keep
telling people a year and a half ago
we were all living our old lives and
wouldn't we love to go back to that but
it just
ain't coming back and people forget what
happened two weeks ago
and then it just kind of keeps moving i
want to give you all a chance to give a
closing statement michaela you've been
sort of the
the most pollyannish the most positive
about this so
after listening to these two guys are
you still there
well to be a little bit more positive
about the police situation
when they announced the second
stay-at-home mandate in ontario the
toronto police did tweet out
they said that the police had the
ability to
stop and question people about why they
were outside their house
so you could potentially get questions
about why you were outside your house
which is ridiculous
and the toronto police on twitter did
tweet out we will not be doing that
which was a kind of a direct response to
this is what the police should be doing
no we're not going to do that so
i still have some hope there but then
there have been instances of police
officers ticketing children in parks
so it's a bit of a disaster
closing statement um i really hope
they roll out the vaccines properly and
everything goes back to normal but
i don't i'm skeptical about the
direction america is heading into
like north america i don't know how
things are gonna look in the next couple
of years
so um i don't i have no idea
dave i have no idea how things are gonna
turn out
she's positive but skeptical either
well i am positively skeptical but
i i keep saying you know it has to get
um
indescribably bad it has to get
intolerably bad
before the silent majority who are there
just hoping things get better quickly
uh realize that they have to be more
proactive in their voicing and be
proactive
um as far as elections go but it has to
get bad enough that even the people who
are in the middle
realize that the world is shifting
around them and whether they like it or
not
it's going to continue unless they start
to uh make changes at the
ballot box and make changes in terms of
public sentiment
but when i hear our health director or i
forget who it is
talking about a qr code for proof of
vaccine
you know i think we're heading in the
wrong direction but you have to head
too far in the wrong direction before
you realize you have to turn back and i
think most people are going to realize
that sooner than later
and i just can't wait for the next
elections yeah well it starts with a qr
code next thing you know they're ripping
your eyeball out and replacing it with
something that they can scan
uh ezra bring us home you know almost a
century ago detroit was america's
leading city by some measures highest
industrial wage cultural capital motown
it was the place to be
now look at it that's bad political
decisions toronto canada
the fourth largest city in north america
a great city in many ways
but justin trudeau just announced he's
planning a
pandemic response well into 2024 and
the lockdowns are getting harsher and
harsher you can
destroy a city a province a whole
country
look at argentina look at venezuela i am
deeply saddened what's happening in
canada i
i don't see the sun rise compared
toronto with miami
miami healthy free growing modern upbeat
toronto sullen
snitch culture informants brutal police
i think that americans should know
what's going on north of the border it
is an experiment
it is a laboratory experiment and if you
don't be careful down south my friends
the bad ideas up here could take root
down there and i'm sorry to be so
black-pilled
but our reporters have been jailed
for what we've talked about here today
so i i'm not feeling optimistic
all right well listen you guys are all
doing great work uh we are gonna link to
the
the crowdfunding uh for the pastor we'll
link to that down below
uh and ezra i'm gonna help you in this
fight against paypal in any way that i
possibly can
i thank you guys i'm gonna continue and
don't worry even though you blackpilled
everyone there
i'm gonna spend the next two minutes
trying to get everybody into the
pleasant weekend mode that's
that's what i do sorry i did that no no
no no look it's real and that's why i
wanted to do this and and the fact that
they're pushing
you know all of you good-natured
canadians you know into becoming
you know crazy radical freedom
extremists maybe that's the silver
lining maybe that really is it
well i thank you guys for doing the show
have a good weekend and i'm just gonna
finish up
by myself over here for a moment so look
you know i think ezra really just nailed
it right there at the end and that's
exactly why i wanted to do this show i
i truly love canada i've been to canada
probably maybe two dozen times
in my life and jordan i did a bunch of
shows up there and as i said i did some
events with maxine bernier
two three years ago who leads the
people's party of canada
which in essence is their libertarian
party and he was warning about all of
this and warning about
cancel culture and warning against about
antifa and identity politics and all of
these things
and it's all here and now there are
these draconian lockdowns and
and as i said before i don't like to do
the oh these people are nazi thing right
because we all get
these horrible labels put on us but at
some point
you know the nazis didn't just show up
one day it wasn't just oh
congratulations here we are we weren't
here yesterday there was no sign that
any of this was coming
it's like what what allows for that
the nazis who are the national
socialists by the way right we've got
the democratic socialists they're the
national
they were the national socialists it's a
slow creep of people being quiet about
things
everyone knowing something's wrong and
no one doing what's right
uh so these are just a couple of the
people that are up in canada fighting
for what's right and and rebel
especially i just think is
just doing great stuff and this paypal
situation i mean think about it what
ezra is telling you is
his company which has existed as an
independent journalist outfit for the
last eight year
i think it's about eight years and he
said they've done about eight million
dollars 175
000 transactions on paypal something
like that just out of nowhere paypal can
just boot them
sorry you're gone that's it no recourse
and it's like now you gotta fight
legally and maybe the legal means
are all we have left anyway i wanted to
do this because i think it's important
to talk about other countries outside of
the united states obviously and and the
things that are happening in every
western country right now
are are happening across borders and we
live in a time with social media that
what happens there
wherever there is it doesn't stay there
it comes here and we export
we from an american perspective export a
lot of this nonsense
and uh we got to fight guys and i and i
hope you will fight and and
all that being said i am hopeful because
people
are waking up as viva said there you
know you can push and push and push and
push
but then eventually people push back and
i did sense this week
that there was a little bit more of a
push back you know chris ruffo who's
doing some great work with some
lawsuits fighting in the states to get
crit critical race theory out
of some of the state curriculums they
got a couple wins
in the last week or two like there are
some good things happening but those
good things
they start and they end with us because
it ain't going to be the politicians
that fix this
on that note guys i want you all have a
great weekend uh
actually my brother is visiting this
weekend so we are not doing a show on
monday i'm taking a rare day off like a
actual day off we will not have a live
stream on monday but i'll be back on
on tuesday and then i'm going to dallas
for a couple days going to do some stuff
with the blaze but i'm just going to eat
some good food and drink some good drink
and you know relax this weekend i hope
you'll do the same
and i'll see you next week and thanks
for watching and have a good day oh and
if you want to see what i'm eating
and what i'm drinking and the other
stuff that i'm doing
reubenreport.locals.com thanks everybody